Other people are like, oh, he's like fine,
if you don't show symptoms
and no one will know
if you don't want to talk about it,
no one will know
and it'll be hidden.
Okay.
The good days.
Other days for like I'm able to wake up,
I like a reasonable time
and like after waking up,
like actually get out of bed and stay
out of bed and like go for a run and do
the things that a normal
human being like can do.
Okay.
Bad days are when I get up late and I
say okay I need to get out of the bed.
And then they don't for like an hour
and then they get out of bed and then
I get back in bed cause I just
like feel like I can't do anything.
Today is August 7th so it is,
we are coming up on so
nine months. Yeah. So,
oh yeah.
Nine months.
It has been nine months. Like I told mom
and dad that my life was falling apart
when he was little. He met,
he was a pretty happy child.
MMM.
As a parent, I wanted to build
a cocoon. I want to protect
my child from all the
bad things in the world.
There's only so many things
you can control. Um, so
the whole process of letting go,
that's hard.
I think after being so quiet,
I can elementary school
and a lot of high school,
I felt like I had something to prove and
they always want us to prove my worth
like through school.
Okay.
What happened was I was like kind of on
the cusp of like a depressive episode in
near the beginning of my fall semester,
stop going to classes,
start sleeping in too late,
causing like a three month
on depressive episode.
I remember Matthew Calling said,
I'm sorry I didn't tell you this sooner
and I'm having real problems with
anxiety and depression.
And I remember wanting
to just somehow reach out
to my him a hug.
Yeah,
you're worthless.
How could you hurt this person?
How could you let yourself
get in this place, Mike?
The answer is constantly just
like, I don't know. I don't
know either. No, no, no.
I get it must be because
I'm an awful person.
He didn't tell me about um,
yeah,
hurting himself
directly. Um, and that's,
I think that's the scariest part.
Matthew's depression that I am actually
a free to know all the details.
Oh,
I had such intense feelings of frustration
and confusion and fear and anger and
then you get to vent them somewhere
and I invented them at myself.
I didn't withdraw from classes
until the day before finals started,
which was the last day you
could withdraw from class.
MMM.
There was,
there was so much pride involved with
going to rice and um,
being a stray procedures
university and like being premed,
they're graduating in four years and I
had to like give all of them up for the
sake of my studio for my health.
Depression is
an illness hidden from view
and silent in so many ways.
People don't want to talk about it,
but it's significant
part of our population
that you can treat and deal with.
It's not the yes.
Yes.
If you will ask me like
what didn't you like?
What did you do when you took time off
from like I found out how to be a normal
human being. Again, I forgot
how to take care of myself
because I didn't care about myself
but definitely something I can say is
I was able to call and
called refocus my life.
My morning routine.
There is so much triumph
like I know I'm just like brushing my
teeth is like very mundane but like on the
inside I'm just like fucking,
yeah,
I rest my team.
Being able to just like do all of
these things and like know that I'm,
I'm ready also to tackle
whatever else comes down already.
Like kids.
It's so encouraging.
I'm really proud of
how we deal with
the hard time set shorter characters.
He's gone through some hard times.
You will still
have days where like nothing will change.
You'll have days where you only
thing regress and feel worse by,
despite that,
I understand that that doesn't define me
and it doesn't define what they can and
can't do. And just focusing, just,
just focusing on that next
step is how before it,
regardless of your religious beliefs,
your,
your, your personal
ideologies, love yourself.
So in terms of like where I am
and my road to recovery, like
I'm still, I'm still just getting up.
I'm still just like sagging to walk,
but like,
I'm still walking.